des milliers de personnes ont vu cet
homme sauvé un inconnu dans la station
de métro la plus achalandée de Montréal
Berry huucam une citoyenne témoin de
sauvetage a même publié cette photo
mercredi un appel à tous pour identifier
et retrouver le héros du jour
le voici Claudio Johnson éboueur à
Montréal depuis une quinzaine d'années
Claudio se rendait au travail lorsqu'il
aperçu l'homme coincé entre les rails
je vois pas le laisser là il est dans 2
minutes le temps plusieurs internautes
ont qualifié l'acte de courageux et même
des reliques
le patron de Claudio lui a montré la
vidéo pour la première fois impressionné
il lui a même offert au nom de sa
compagnie 200 dollars soit l'équivalent
d'une journée de congés payés c'est le
héros de l'équipe
[Musique]
la Société de transport de Montréal a
réagi à l'événement nous saluons le
courage et l'esprit civique du client
mais descendre sur la voie alors que le
métro est alimenté comporte un grand
danger en effet se retrouver sur les
rails pu entraîner des dangers
d'électrocution qui peuvent être fatales
la STM recommande plutôt l'usage des
bornes d'assistance présente à chaque
station à l'intérieur un levier pour
couper le courant et un téléphone rouge
pour contacter le centre de contrôle
mais Claudio a préféré sauter ça
m'étonne pas de Closer c'est quelqu'un
de courageux vaillant dans la vie
cette éboueur d'expérience se réjouit
des retombées positives du sauvetage de
son employé aujourd'hui cl
[Musique]
Audy et tous ses collègues ici j'espère
que son acte de courage va demeurer une
source d'inspiration ici Alexis
tremblait Radio-Canada à Montréal